à quelque chose exilés bon les
traditions culturelles sont finalement
plus facile à faire vivre loin de
l'occupant chinois qui a voulu les
éradiquer alma ata les hommes ouïghours
se retrouve par exemple dans des soirées
de discussion très codifié qu'ils
appellent machrab le mach rap se déroule
sous la tente et on y parle volontiers
politique
on prospecte les hommes qui participent
thomas shroud doivent respecter
rigoureusement les règles ils sont les
vrais hommes ceux qui sont responsables
a jamais de leur peur c'est un maître de
cérémonie qui règle la séquence des
activités
[Musique]
le gouvernement chinois a interdit les
machrek en les accusant de subversion
mais ces rencontres où l'alcool et la
drogue sont interdits sont bons pour la
santé mentale des ouïghours il s'agit en
fait de nous éloigner de notre culture
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez
le cul
[Musique]
dans les petites communautés de la
diaspora ouïgoure d'asie centrale
on retourne souvent le couteau dans la
plaie on évoque la répression les
tortures infligées par la police
chinoise
pire encore les abus du planning
familial communiste les femmes dans leur
quartier
les hommes entre eux car chaque fête est
une occasion de rassemblement et des
vocations au turkestan oriental le
planning familial et inhumain
sous prétexte de limiter les naissances
à 2 maximum par couple et d'interdire
absolument le troisième enfant on
pratique la stérilisation forcée sur des
centaines de milliers de nos femmes nos
mères et nos soeurs sont emmenés à
l'hôpital de force pour subir des
avortements
[Musique]
on jette des milliers de foetus vos
ordures
[Musique]